bonjour d'abord une réaction autour de
la Ligue des droits de l'homme car cet
après-midi on a beaucoup parlé de ce
sujet pendant les questions d'actualité
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
remettre en cause les subventions à
cette association alors que on a entendu
le sénateur les républicains François
bonhomme et bien dénoncer les prises de
position récente de la LDH et également
le gouvernement à la chef du
gouvernement Elisabeth band s'interroger
sur ses prises de position de la LDH
écoutez les deux ont eu raison François
bonhomme c'est notre LR donc de mon
groupe et tout comme Elisabeth borde
première ministre ont eu raison de
pointer un certain nombre d'incohérences
une sorte d'extrême gauche
de la Ligue des droits de l'homme qui a
eu sans doute un noble passé un passé
glorieux mais quitte en train de se
perdre dans des querelles et dans un
certain nombre de problématiques
d'extrême gauche par exemple lorsque
elle attaque qu'un arrêté pour que
Hassan Soline s'est arrêté voulait
interdire le transport d'armes par
destination ça veut dire quoi qu'est-ce
que ça à voir avec les droits de l'homme
on veut consacrer justement cette
mauvaise habitude que certains de
transporter des armes par destination
des armes par destination dans un coffre
de voiture ça sert à quoi ça sert à
blesser ça peut servir à tuer quand il
est été faire dans cette cause qui est
une mauvaise cause
idem lorsque il a fallu à l'époque le
Gouvernement a souhaité dissoudre une
organisation notoirement islamiste le
CCIF à nouveau on retrouve la Ligue des
droits de l'Homme donc qui a non
seulement une incohérence il y a une
terrible ambiguïtée et même une
complicité que je dénonce aussi
aujourd'hui à cette antenne donc sur le
vous il faut couper les subventions de
LDH je pense qu'il faut les remettre en
cause si elle ne change pas s'il n'est
pas conforme si ses actions ne sont pas
conformes à son objet social en quoi les
droits de l'homme ont-ils avoir quelque
chose avec la capacité de transporter
des armes par destination c'est une
question que je vous pose
alors je vais vous poser une autre
question sur les forces de l'ordre
puisque aujourd'hui au Sénat une
proposition de résolution déposée par la
droite sénatoriale et bien va être
débattue une proposition de résolution
pour soutenir reconnaître l'action des
forces de l'ordre quel est l'objet de ce
texte de mettre notamment les
parlementaires de gauche devant
certaines de leurs contradictions dans
leur discours sur la police l'objectif
il est simple ça n'est pas une
résolution uniquement et simplement
symbolique c'est une résolution
profondément politique pourquoi parce
qu'on voit bien que face à cette
violence qui se déchaîne va être à cette
haine de ceux qui nous protègent il faut
aussi les protéger il faut monter au
créneau lorsque le Runner est même leur
intégrité physique est attaquée la
première ministre l'a rappelé depuis
plusieurs mois plus de 1000 gendarmes
policiers sapeurs-pompiers ont été
physiquement blessés parfois grièvement
et on voit bien qu'il y a une complicité
notamment de l'ultra gauche de l'extrême
gauche quand des élus par exemple mère
parlementaires à Sainte Céline vont avec
leur écharpe tricolore dans une
manifestation qui n'est pas voir dans
d'autres manifestations interdites mais
je pense que en réalité il manque à leur
devoir délurépublicain et je pense qu'à
un moment donné trop c'est trop et ça
suffit il faut réaffirmer solidairement
la reconnaissance la gratitude de toute
la nation c'est pas une question c'est
pas une affaire de parti politique pour
moi on pète de gauche de droite et
soutenir la République l'ordre
républicain et donc les forces de
l'ordre dernière question Bruno
Retailleau cette historique pour la
première fois le Parlement a rejeté à la
nomination proposée par un président de
la République la nomination et bien du
président à la tête de l'ADEME l'Agence
de la transition écologique c'était
Boris Ravignon le maire de
Charleville-Mézières dans les Ardennes
qui était proposé les deux chambres du
Parlement ont rejeté cette nomination
Boris Ravignon qui d'ailleurs est plutôt
Macron compatible et bien dénonce des
consignes notamment donné par les
présidents de groupe parlementaires de
droite qu'est-ce que vous voulez
répondez d'abord que les sénateurs sont
des femmes et des hommes qui sont
profondément libres et si il n'a pas eu
la majorité de voix sans prendre à
lui-même on essayait en réalité de nous
faire passer cette humiliation pour une
simple formalité l'exécutif là d'abord
pour quelques mois nommer pensant
qu'ensuite ce sera vraiment une simple
formalité d'obtenir et des régler cette
domination à l'eau de l'article 13 de la
Constitution mais voilà le Parlement est
un parlement adulte et on ne peut pas si
j'ose dire couvrir toutes les
nominations c'est une nomination pour un
certain nombre de raisons qui ne cadrait
pas et bien nous l'avons exprimé de
façon très large sur le plan politique
donc le Parlement est là pour vérifier
un certain nombre de choses et
l'exécutif ne peut pas demander
systématiquement au Parlement de
ratifier ces moindres désirs c'est moins
caprice je veux simplement dire que sur
le plan des domination il y a énormément
à dire on a monsieur pavinotti qui a
loupé une nomination récemment dans une
autre autorité administrative qu'on va
nous reproposer donc c'est un éternel
recyclage donc la question et surtout la
réponse qu'on a apporté à la question
c'est dire STOP les recyclage merci
beaucoup Bruno retailleux pour
vos réponses
[Musique]